dan simmons wrote the first book in the
Hyperion cantos in 1989 in this series
he followed in the footsteps of classic
science-fiction writers like Frank
Herbert and Isaac Asimov
since its release Hyperion has come to
be known as one of the essential
science-fiction books to come out of the
past three decades the series which
contains four books is set among the
stars within the hegemony of man
[Music]
the hegemony of man was the name given
to the political and cultural entity
which came to be after the event known
as the Hegira before the existence of
the hegemony the cradle of humanity
Earth had been destroyed by the event
afterward referred to as the big mistake
it was said to be a catastrophic
occurrence that caused the earth to be
consumed from the inside out
by a man created black hole over the
course of 100 years as the planet was
annihilated from within the Hegira began
the mass diaspora of humankind from the
planet earth and into the Stars the
results of the Hegira man's great exodus
from the planet Earth was the hegemony
which eventually would connect over 150
billion human beings inhabiting 200
planets there are also about 200 planets
considered protectorate of the hegemony
which were only reachable through
traditional means of space travel
these outback worlds were not connected
by far castor or fat line this means
that in traveling to these worlds time
debt is accumulated for instance two
weeks traveling at near light speed
would equate to about one standard year
relative to those outside of the ship
the planet Hyperion was one of such
worlds the planet Hyperion stood out for
several reasons it was the location of
the mysterious time tombs which had
appeared on the world at some point they
had been sent backward in time from some
point in the future another reason was
that Hyperion was the place where the
Shrike resided a deadly being which had
appeared on the planet at the same time
as the tombs the Church of the final
atonement or Shrike Church built a
temple on the world the strike was their
avatar their Lord of pain hundreds of
thousands of believers from throughout
the hegemony made the pilgrimage to the
strike temple Hyperion was also one of
the hegemonies nine labyrinthine worlds
these worlds each contain strange
complex underground tunnels it is
speculated that they
had been created by some ancient long
gone race referred to in the series as
the builders the hegemony of man's
government consisted of a bicameral
legislature ruled by the Senate the
Senate CEO who was essentially a
president and the whole thing the public
forum which could be accessed by any
member of the hegemony through calm logs
neural implants through which citizens
of the hegemony could be given
information about the state of the
Empire the all thing had evolved a
consciousness of its own through the all
thing citizens were able to vote on a
hundred different laws per day if they
chose the all thing was maintained by
artificial intelligence systems and was
dependent on fat line and far caster
technology the hegemonies armed forces
was collectively known as force many of
the soldiers were trained at the Olympus
command school which was built on a dead
volcano on the surface of the planet
Mars which was the first planet to be
colonized during the Hegira after the
big mistake force contained four
branches a marine force a space force a
Navy force and a ground force the
headquarters of force was located on Tau
Ceti Center a planet less than 12
light-years from old Earth's solar
system Tau Ceti center was the central
world of inhabited space and the capital
of the hegemony tens of billions of
humans lived there on the surface and
among the ring of habitats and cities in
orbit above the planet Tau Ceti Center
was also the center of the hegemony of
man's datum plane web mega sphere the
datum plane was the aggregate of all
real-time networks generated by computer
and AI the web mega sphere was one of
the two main data spheres within it the
other one was the Technic or matrix by
communicating through members of its AI
council the Technic or maintain an
advisory position within the hegemony
making predictions for the government
the techno core and the hegemony
government sustained a cooperative
relationship though the techno core had
a distant :
indicative of its inhuman nature for the
hegemony the techno core also created
many different technologies most notably
far casters and fat line technology
beyond the grip of the hegemony are the
ouster z' they were a society of humans
spread throughout the galaxy who
colonized the outer edges of human space
they had begun to set themselves apart
from the rest of humankind during the
beginning days of the Hegira in the four
books of the Hyperion cantos the ouster
remained the enemy of the hegemony and
later packs throughout the series much
about the actual nature of the ouster z'
is revealed
dan simmons provides in the Hyperion
cantos a strange and mysterious and
pretty scary universe I love the fact
that there are mysteries like what the
techno core is really up to or where the
time tooms came from or what exactly is
the purpose of these labyrinthine worlds
and who exactly were these ancient
builders and do they still exist
somewhere Dan Simmons is able to make
his Universe feel large and complex and
even convoluted at times without it
becoming overwhelming and without making
it feel like a non-stop barrage of names
and places that don't seem real the
hegemony of man controlled the majority
of the worlds that humankind had
inhabited though the citizens through
connection with the all thing could
participate in democracy the hegemony
was essentially a dictatorship led by
senators from various worlds many
planets had been forced into the
hegemony and no planet was permitted to
leave those who resisted would risk
being slaughtered by the military arm of
the hegemony which as I mentioned was
called force though the hegemony of
mankind marked a great achievement for
Humanity even away from the planet Earth
humans faced great struggles and
oppression
the hegemony of man perhaps like all
empires was destined one day to fall
thank you guys so much for watching if
you liked the video and want to see more
content make sure you like and subscribe
and if you want to support this channel
click the patreon link in the
description also check out the ideas of
Ice and Fire subreddit and follow me on
Twitter all of my links are in the
description